good afternoon post lunch first session
my name is William tullik or Bill
tullock I use both I also respond to hey
you just in case you're wondering
um I have recently become a principal
software engineer at Microsoft and
previously I was a principal consultant
at Telstra purple
I have a confession to make
I made a mistake
when I first put this talk in and
proposed it
I was thinking oh I'm just going to do a
slightly more reasoned less sweary
version of a talk I did last year called
I hate web development
and there's truth in that as well oh
yeah this is this is going to be really
easy and if you want to keep a swear
counter going please someone keep count
because it's going to happen sooner or
later
um
but then and here's the thing when we're
working on stuff when we're in we're in
the the heart of the engine we're not
really paying attention to what's going
on outside you know maybe a Twitter
Twitter thing you say oh someone's
talking about a new framework or you
know you've you're watching TV and
browsing Facebook though I don't get
anything about technology and Facebook
so I stepped out and I said right I'll
start doing my research there's a couple
of things I'd heard about server side
rendering I thought that's curious
and then I went down the rabbit hole
I have spent two months reading articles
upon article upon article I've had 100
tabs open at any one time in my browser
I my reality fragmented and unraveled
and mutated I had lost sight of where
the world was my certainty about what I
was doing was on a precipice
and that's the talk I'm going to give
you today
because all of that goes to what this is
about
in what we are going to cover very
Loosely and with different degrees of
ranting
is a bit about the history and I'll
explain in a second we're going to look
at some of the things that have are
coming up that are surfacing on the web
and then in blog posts and stuff about
the state of web development and then
I'm probably going to round it out with
my thoughts on where we're at and what
we should be doing
um I'm happy for interjections if you
really want to ask a question please
feel free so
you may ask yourself how did we get here
we've been doing web development for
close on 25 to 30 years in one form or
another it is not unused Tech stack
anymore it's older than.net which is my
preferred place of residence
but and part of what I'm seeing is that
I think we are not seeing we're not
remembering our history either
um so as part of this talk I'm going to
give you a quick context because it is
worthwhile knowing how we got to where
we are now
as well as knowing what's happening now
because they actually influence each
other
so this is a very poorly
written out timeline it is neither
accurate in scale or dates
but it will do and that little yellow
dot is when I started working in web
development
so I have unfortunately been the victim
of my own Madness and have been doing
this for a long time but there are some
key things here 1990 to 1995 really this
is you know from the moment we kind of
started thinking about HTML in that
period the proposal for CSS was put
forward JavaScript was invented
um that all happened that period I'm not
going to go over that it's kind of you
can look it up much easier
1996 to 1999 whereas when things really
started happening standardization was a
thing that we were finally actually
trying to consider
um but browser compliance with site
number one and the browser was ignited
at that point what did a browse wall
consist of
Microsoft developing ie and Netscape
and it went on and as a developer this
was incredibly frustrating even though
we had Suite fa in terms of CSS styling
and stuff it still caused problems when
we were trying to develop applications
Microsoft being the sneaky people that
down
I'm just checking for ninjas because
making comments about my my organization
now
got around this by saying right we're
going to stick I.E on every operating
system
and they surprisingly won the
temporarily the browser War for a period
of time Netscape kind of dribbled off
Mozilla came up and then it went on but
the browser walls are a bit like the
hundred year war in in Europe it wasn't
a continuous fight and it wasn't
continuous War it was a lot of series of
skirmishes and as a developers we were
the
the victims of this it was our Villages
they came and burnt down when they were
having a bit of a spat right
um I mean and even within one type of
browser so IE is a classic example
on Windows that did one thing on on the
Mac it did another so I worked at a
travel
group and travel agents were using Max
and weird stuff was happening it was
totally inverting all the colors no idea
so I literally spent one day running two
and a half blocks from Swanson Street up
exhibition Street to a friend's art
design school because they had Max
and I never fixed it so we were always
caught out by the lack of standards and
the inability of these two or three or
four people to actually agree on
anything
um 2006 2000 22 000 to 2006 I did have
to update the other day we started
seeing CSS Frameworks coming through
they weren't that predominant
um the big one is the jQuery came about
now why did we get jQuery jQuery
we forget that it was the first library
that made working with JavaScript and
interacting with the Dom easier it
actually took out a lot of boilerplate
code for us and it was a good thing then
and this is again and it helped us with
the performance of our code
so jQuery became a thing at that point
also front-end package management we
started seeing
things for managing packages his names I
can't remember anymore because it was
that long ago
um the other one I missed which is up
the top 96 Flash
and I'll pivot back to that and I also
worked with that so
what a lot of us forget is trying to do
any decent design work in HTML was a
fight
two
um
you know we I don't does anyone ever
remember the one gift spacer
yeah so yeah we we created one pixel
spaces so we could actually take a
design that a designer did in Photoshop
the lovely deers chop it up and either
use give spaces or tables to lay it out
both totally inappropriate but that's
what we did so when flash came along it
gave designers actually a much better
palette to work with and they gave us a
way of actually saying hey we can
actually make this look like a real
application
during the flash era the one thing I do
remember was that has anyone seen escape
from LA
one person I am talking to a younger
audience
um and when that came out that was the
sequel to escape from New York
the big thing was they built a game in
Flash with our hero
snake pliskin playing basketball and it
was a big hit it was great and so flash
was going really well but it was a lot
more for websites you wouldn't build an
application with it
um
2007 the release of the iPhone
now this is critical and we'll come back
to why that is critical coincidentally
same year Microsoft really Silverlight
and again he wasn't we suddenly had a
way where we could build
business applications without the
constraints that HML was imposing on us
so we could you know it was based on
xaml so we could take stuff we'd done in
WPF because that was also pretty hip at
the time
and we could build real world business
applications we could have proper tables
we could do stuff we could send WCF
messages
and if anyone remembers that you've
unfortunate
um
but the iPhone release
this is had probably the largest impact
on where we are in terms of web
development because what it did is it
suddenly put the world in everyone's
pocket
prior to this when we were building web
applications you'll say well I'm a
monitor 640 by 480 you know bang that's
it cool I can just do that you actually
have the cable you've got to be plugged
in you can't use it otherwise the iPhone
suddenly said well I can be anywhere I
still want to get to my web pages my web
application and that's when things
really started changing key things have
come out are the concepts like
responsive design mobile first but
probably the real big one was single
page applications
so why
did the phone have that impact because
we suddenly started realizing that a
full bodied web application that was
reloading every page every time you
navigated on another link or to another
menu item was too heavy
the you know this is 3G period so the
amount of load that that required was
too great
so then there are ideas coming up and
said well hey what we should do so that
they have a sense that something's
happening is we load a shell so an HTML
page
loads a little bit of JavaScript comes
up and then we can push other stuff up
what we also did is we started working
with apis and in the sense of
calling a back end
and just getting some data in we won't
have them call the back back to the
server and pull the whole page up we're
going to say hey give me the starter I'm
going to come in here and I'll display
it and that way we saw things like
backbone Amber angularjs start coming to
the front and that this is the birth of
rock and roll and single page
applications
and it was great
you know of most of those early
libraries were based on the model view
star pattern
but it worked we were actually now able
to create Dynamic views we were able to
control the amount of data was coming
and we were improving the performance of
the applications at that period also h75
was announced another small game changer
I read something in my Mad Dash around
the interweb that a75 was introduced to
stop Flash
the other thing that stopped flash was
that Apple wouldn't support it
all silver light so the kind of neutral
now my current boss just as a side story
around this time wrote a book called
integrating silver light with the zero
um and I was a technical reviewer
literally
two days before it came out Microsoft
announced that they were no longer going
to support Silverlight
yeah he didn't get much royalties on
that one
unfortunate 2016 to 220
we are much closer to where we are now
um we're seeing improvements in Native
HTML
the hml5 stuff's coming in we have a
better sense of what it's doing we're
seeing browser apis improving and giving
us more functionality
this is also when we started getting
applications like the reactors a bit
earlier we started moving further into
spars so new versions of angular react
were coming in we were getting more
confident with building these
applications which brings us
to 2021
what year is it
2022. I knew I was somewhere near that
okay and that's where we are so that's
kind of the history
and all the things that have influenced
it they've all had an effect key things
that keep coming up and this of course
have been performance so when we started
having to use web pages and websites and
applications on mobile devices
performance becomes an issue usability
becomes an issue things like that the
reoccurring themes
okay so what's the current state of play
so 30 years of the web
be pretty mature by now he's got his
comfy slippers on maybe a pipe feed up
cocktail it's looking good
not really
so I I feel like the web world is is
kind of like a small boy in big trousers
you know that the constantly running
around screaming their heads off there
are good things that have happened we
have seen the death of IE which has
recently announced
big bonus I just hope all the hospitals
can afford to update their operating
system so they also can enjoy that
benefit
um we're also
brain just stopped working it will get
there
you know we have seen things like
service workers pwa coming in the
browsers are becoming much more
compliant so one of the biggest issues
we had in the past was that
you know I'm developing on browser X
Chrome and someone calls up and says I'm
on Firefox and looks like
three
um
we've got a place now especially when
Microsoft went and decided to use the
chromium engine that we've actually can
have a reasonably high level of
assurance that when we build something
that it's going to work pretty well as
long as we've designed it properly in
most browsers with minor exceptions
which means we're not having to worry
about vendor prefixing or writing
JavaScript that's going to go if I.E do
this if not do something else which was
kind of what jQuery sold for us a little
bit
but
all is not well in the forest
so in my reading
there's been a lot of complaints
people are getting riled up
and one of the key ones is performance
now yeah I'm I'm not sure but one of the
suppositions I have is that in in 2020
Google had said that their current
web vitals core
which measures things like first
contentful paint first time first time
to interaction will impact on your
search
oh I've got a SEO search experience
optimization
and this has caused
amazing a number of issues for people
are blogging about this all the time
admittedly I could have been on a q Anon
site but I'm not sure but I'm pretty
sure that this is this is what's
happening and so this thing about
performance is coming up again
and it's I find this really interesting
because this is always the thing we keep
coming up against when we first started
working on Spa applications it was well
we want to improve the performance by
only loading what we need
but we're 10 12 years down the track in
developing Spa applications
the other aspect of performance and I'll
touch on later is the user developer
experience we're going to make the
developer experience faster and faster
it's going to compile before you've even
blinked
I'm not sure I'm convinced about that
but that's the way it is so performance
is sort of an umbrella thing that an
issue that's cropping up what do we get
from out of that
single page applicants are not so shiny
now
this kind of makes sense because what's
happened over 10 to 12 years we're
making these things more complex people
are adding more JavaScript the concern
that is being expressed is things like
well you know if I've start my
application up it's got the load all the
JavaScript all the components
irrespective of the bundles or not and
that's taking too long which
coincidentally impacts my score which
impacts my SEO rating now
foreign
okay good so
one of the thoughts that I came out is
because they said oh but my website is
loading too low and my score and Google
search is going to be down and I'm
thinking why are you writing a website
with single page application
I mean we're talking marketing sites
maybe a blog site
you know it might be might have a cart
who knows why are you writing it as a
single page application
but what they've done is well all the
hip kids are writing single page
applications so that's what we write and
now I'm going to complain about it
this doesn't mean they're wrong it just
means they're slightly misguided and
this is driving a lot of what the
conversations are about the concept of
how long this takes to happen what's the
hydration can we do partial hydration
I've Island hydration I think that was a
term I hit very interesting so that's
that's a big player at the moment we're
also hearing people talking about
multi-page applications
to me that just sounds like a website I
wrote in 1996 you know I kind of get
there is there it is not quite that and
I think this is the thing
um
the
the browsers and and and the mechanics
behind this have improved browsers can
now if you load up some CSS and
JavaScript
in your first page and you have that
reference in your second page it doesn't
reload it it says hey yeah I know I got
that that's cool we've got caching that
actually works a lot better so it's not
that stupid but it does feel a little
weird and also it's what it's putting
into question is and one of the reasons
we had Spas was because you know we said
client routing is faster
so a lot of what we did aside from
pulling the data was saying well if I
load up all these components we can use
client routing it's not calling back to
the server so we're cool
that it is people are now saying well no
now that isn't the fact things have
changed so
server-side rendering and friends so I'm
going to be honest the first time I saw
I saw SSR and they're saying well SSR
This Ss and I said what is SSR turns out
server side rendering we also get SSG
static site generation
these are very exciting so what you will
now see if you look around is a lot of
Articles discussing pros and cons of
these things as I said you know I think
concepts of hydration what should be
hydrating should we you know how can we
reduce the amount of JavaScript and
loading
um I know reacts got server-side some
server-side rendering stuff and we'll
discuss this more when we look at
Frameworks and libraries but this one is
there's the big is the Big Kahuna at the
moment
I've just put this up because this
amuses me there's also a zero JavaScript
um kind of clique the kind of like
they're like the really weird Q Anon
people
um this is a bit like back in the day
JavaScript was evil so when we were
building web applications corporations
and companies everywhere shove off
JavaScript
you can't load JavaScript you can't have
cookies cookies are evil as well this is
sort of not quite that this is the quite
slightly lesser evil JavaScript but
there is this idea that says well maybe
we don't need JavaScript
I mean there are hypothetical things
like wasm maybe that's that I have heard
discussions about rust
being a contender for taking over from
JavaScript but I just put this up
because I I think it's it would look
great on the T-shirt so anyone wants
that you can have it
finally the gradient of the learning
curve and the DX developer experience so
on one hand we've got discussions about
performance of the applications on the
other hand we've got discussion about
the performance of our developers now
one of the things you say oh well you
know application X or you know framework
X it's got a very steep learning curve
doesn't everything have a steep learning
curve
you know and what are we talking about
you mean you're saying that your people
your developers are stupid
and actually now I've worked for a
company that did think that
they they actually hired stupid people
so they could control them
sort of like a cult but not quite but
this is one of these conversations a
couple of when we're looking at
Frameworks and libraries you know oh
what's the learning curve oh this one's
got a very smooth learning curve
I want my people to learn
things are difficult to learn I've been
practicing martial arts for 25 years I
am still learning
you know this is it so I always think
this is a bit of a fur fee you know it's
unless something is so opaque
or in my case python which is my current
wet Noir
um I don't this will stop something but
it is it's what gets discussed a lot the
other one's the DX experience you know
um this framework it's
um one of the ones you're getting now is
because
um es modules have really kind of
mainstream
um you can Frameworks for developers
that don't bundle so you take the build
out that's great or you know it will
only build what you've changed good
don't use webpack use vitae
faster slower you know all of these
things but that's what a lot of
conversations again it's about the speed
and that's the part that worries me what
are you doing running a coal mine and
using children in it I don't think so
yes we want to be reactive we want to be
able to respond quickly and stuff but I
remember you know when I used to compile
code back in early 90s I actually
enjoyed the fact I'd go and have a
coffee while it did its thing and I'm
not even going to discuss rendering 3D
animations there was a whole night
exercise but that's one of the other
ones and that's some of the sales
pitches we get
good
so
my library is better than your library
this one is you know we get this a lot
um
so back in the day like maybe two years
ago
because time's moving quickly you know
when we were looking at front-end
Frameworks uh react angular and a side
view would view usually it was the
reactant angular and when I was in
ratify that was a common
argument you know you know angular gives
you everything it you know it's a
complete framework oh it's too
regimented
why does it do that react
it's a bit like buying a kick car and
all he gets the engine you know you've
got to work out all the other bits
you've got to put onto it so I have
freedom with react whereas angular is
sort of kind of like you know
pointy-headed boss but that was what we
were talking about and then View kind of
was sitting in there and this one you
saw when you were driving past in the
car but things are moving on we're
seeing more libraries coming out so the
first one has failed anyone heard us
felt
yeah look I think it's really
interesting it takes a slightly
different approach because what I'd say
it it's not using jsx I'm going to point
that out it actually it sits closer it's
more like a subset of HTML
but it compiles it into your JavaScript
and so again what are the reasons for
this is it gives us a cost benefit we
are actually it did it again
and I think I'll put it up here
thank you
um
and I think that's a really interesting
idea and I'm not going to spend too long
on these I've done too many to-do lists
I really want to bother with it anymore
but it's worth having a look at I kind
of like it but it's also syntactically
it feels a little strange
the next one which is also come up on
the radar in the last year is solid.js
again a very interesting one this is
almost like a response to react it uses
jsx
but I think it's typescript first but
what they're pushing is the idea of
taking out the complexity of react
because developers struggle with
complexity
um they've done things like they've
reduced the way hooks work if you're
familiar with react you know making that
simpler they've
they've modified the way you can write
your code and again they're looking at
ways of using kind of you like primitive
reactives so that it's more efficient in
processing it and it doesn't the big one
it doesn't use a virtual Dom so unlike
react which keeps a virtual Dom and then
has to walk it to find a change and then
push it back out
this doesn't use anything like that I've
had a small play with it it's quite nice
um
next one web components anyone who knows
me knows I have been a long time
advocate for web components and it has
felt like an uphill fight for a long
time as well but they again have come to
the mainstream we now have browsers that
can support web components natively we
have libraries like lit which makes
writing them easier and we have large
organizations who are actually building
web component libraries Microsoft graph
toolkit is written in web components
github's got web components IBM's got
web components
which I don't know if that's a you know
a good thing or a bad thing but there
you go
probably needs a 5.4 floppy disk as well
um
but I think I I'm going to say this
these need to be looked at most of these
Frameworks with the exception of react
which still requires a wrapper at this
point will support web components
natively so if you need to build
presentation pieces this is a good way
because the key thing is it's actually
part of the specification for w3c web
components are specif they are
a specification they're not something
built onto the side
and the last one I'm just calling this
out this one mitosis which I think is an
unfortunate name if you come from
Australia and know about rabbits
sounds like myxomatosis
um this one is the most interesting one
it's only in beta but it's essentially
an Intermediate Language compiler
not quite but what it does it has its
own syntax
um I think it's kind of based on jsx
don't quote me I'm not looking at my
notes but what it does do is that it
will take that and compile it into a
Json structure
from that Json structure
you can create a component in any
library that you want
So currently on this site
supports react angular
svelt Swift
web components straight HTML so I can
build a component
push it through their little serializer
which generates like an intermediate
point which is Json and then it's like I
want angular components thanks and it
will actually go and build those out for
you now of all of these
I really hope that one succeeds because
it will actually address a lot of the
issues we currently have with long-term
running projects and stuff like that so
it's worth keeping your eye on them
okay
the great thing with the exception of
angular angular sort of feels like the
key to came to a form or when everyone
else was in fancy dress
um
stop that
it's still flashing isn't it yeah
okay I'm just going to go with most
libraries what we end up saying and
reacts the classic case so yeah racked
here it is completely unopinionated do
what you want
but then you've got to think about all
the other stuff so what we end up seeing
coming about are Frameworks which
actually allow us to do the rest of the
building of the application so it
happens if I change slides
um and again there's a number of these
some are not so new they're probably the
most common one is next JS if you're
doing react stuff
um it basically sells itself as a
framework for supporting uh react but
where again it's the key things on the
cross nearly all of these is that it's
saying we can handle server-side
rendering for you
we have the smarts to be able to go
through your code work out what we can
send up without JavaScript work out what
we need to send some JavaScript with
work out what we can just render on the
server and then send it completed with
whatever data you've pulled in send it
to the server that's its big cell it has
a page-based routing system so it
actually uses files on your router so
you drop your files in bang and it
routes to them and then when it needs to
do something on the client side it can
do it
remix is kind of like the the young
Contender it's come through I had a note
about remix
so this has been developed by the people
behind react router it's kind of it's
kind of trying to say oh we we do it
even better than xjs we're really cool
they're only sort of cool there are
actually underneath the covers some
structural differences about a thing
from memory next.js is kind of
node-based
and remix is just more of an API based
system
but they do similar things again
server-side rendering is managed parcel
hydration hydration removing JavaScript
etc etc etc
so that's that one spell kit I'm not
going to talk about too much it's
essentially it is the framework for
working with sveld so svelt will allow
you to create components spell kick does
the rest of it and again
and it's going to get really boring very
soon server side rendering etc etc etc
Marco
um they actually came out of eBay
um that it had been behind eBay's walls
they developed about
200 to 13.
um and they've only just recently made
it open source key thing about this it's
not a react framework whereas remix and
next star this is not it actually uses a
super set of HTML which it then extends
I just really I think you're going to be
focused more around websites than say
web applications but no it's there
quick
the quick thing just saying a chance to
single itself saying it has the goal of
instant applications so it's going to
strip everything out and your
application is going to load immediately
again I think it's more of a website
based
approach I haven't had a lot of time
with it I've I've kind of tested some of
the others but not with that one and the
final one is is Astro
so Astro is kind of it's not like Marco
but I'll say just a moment Astro is very
much phonics towards static websites
from what I can understand but guess
what you can use it with react sveld
okay I've got let me just check my list
here because I hate getting this wrong
whoops
let me go back there
and try to drive the scroll bar
so react spell view solid Alpine lit and
Vanilla Java script so it says we can
work with any of these but and we'll
create static websites from it no that's
fine
whatever rocks their boat are seriously
not going to give it too much time
unless suddenly there's a major you know
transform in the universe but again it's
worth looking at these to see how they
view the problems and how they go about
solving them so I'm not discrediting any
of them I'm just not going to play
favors either
so
if you go to any of these sites these
are marketing sites
and every single one of them is going to
go where performance server-side
rendering great developer experience
we play pokers on Sundays
you know it's a bit like going to a
salad bar and every salad's just tomato
and lettuce
there's just 10 of them they're all
tomato and lettuce
what do we do
and what do developers do and this is
the part I need to get to next my
concern is with this Cornucopia of
choices
developers are going to do probably one
of three things stick a towel over their
head and hope Armageddon shows up soon
spent all their time reading to-do lists
you know not to do to do at least come
next but you know top 10 JavaScript
Frameworks I have read 20 of those
and I still didn't have an answer
um or you'll sit there and you go oh I'm
going to go and do a to-do list and
literally my laptop now is just full of
sample to-do lists and I think one
sample blog post or worse you actually
get smarter so okay I'm going to make a
decision I'm going to choose framework Y
and then you're going to spend the rest
of your time looking over the fence
because the Grass Is Always Greener over
there wondering what you're missing out
on we are in an awkward position
I I kind of regret that there's so much
going on in this world but there seems
to be this thing that no one can stop
Reinventing the wheel or trying to build
a better mousetrap
doesn't mean it's wrong but and you know
and if we're looking at Market forces
yes competition is good it drives things
but for us whoever got to work with the
stuff making these decisions are
difficult
Okay so
where does that leave us
as you can probably guess my personal
opinion on the current state of
framework designing is exciting in many
ways but I'm also think that it's we're
creating for a rotter for our own back
the key one is that we're looking at
issues of performance and we're seeing
that the only solution is to throw more
technology at it
now
I kind of get that we're software
developers everything can be fixed with
technology we're all bash script
whatever you want to do but
this worries me I think are we are we
possibly going down a path we shouldn't
um
my key thing is and part of the kind of
where this talk is heading is we should
be thinking about what we're doing
we should be reviewing what we're doing
over the last couple of years I picked
up
um a I took over responsibility for an
application that I actually wrote 10
years ago now
thank you ljs users require doesn't have
npm but funnily enough it's got some
Oddities in it it was really easy to
keep working on it because it was well
set up and well structured
I also took over another one which had
been start and reacting so consequently
for the first time I actually had the
learn react and anger as opposed to kind
of oh that looks interesting
um and there were decisions made in that
which I could see were going to cause US
problems and would introduce performance
issues at some point down the track
so these are some small thoughts it's
going to be reasonably random
focus on the goal not the means it was
like great for t-shirts I'll sell it to
you if you want
um
too often look we get excited why are
you in this conference because this
stuff excites you because you love
technology you're like you we're all
squirrels oh shiny thing you know this
is good but
we have to remember what are we building
why are we building it and the decision
shouldn't be based on the technology
stack you pick but on what you were
trying to get done then come back and
decide what is the best approach for
that technology
um I know that takes some of the fun out
of it I'm sorry but in the end whoever's
using your website or your web
application and just to be clear I've
never built that website I've done web
apps that's what I do you know I build
dashboards for Health Systems which you
know Critical Care 24 7. I have to worry
about how it's going to work for them
and so do you
the user doesn't care
whether you build a road in a notepad
it's built on ASP
dot net or whatever doesn't mean
anything it's completely meaningless
does it do what they needed to do and
we've got to always come back to that
because if we don't we're being untrue
to ourselves and we are making it worse
for our end users
okay don't believe the hype
so it just goes back to my whole
marketing pitch
if you are looking at a framework or
you're giving a consideration
read the small print it's really good
don't just rely and look on most these
sites are great they'll have like a you
know 10 step 20-step tutorial take you
through the basics you know at the end
of it you get a little certificate
no you don't get a certificate that's
the certification
and it looks great but
what you really need to do is to take it
for a good long run my recommendation is
if you are considering applications
you're saying hey this has got some
features I really like this is really
cool
I think we could really benefit from
this
do develop spike out a real world
workflow one of the things I do is I've
got a couple of applications that again
we've written 10 years ago but what I do
is I say this stuff works and you know
it has these particular set of problems
so I will then try and recreate it in a
different framework or in a different
library because it gives me a baseline
to measure it against so don't just pick
it up because it's cool and shiny ask
yourself what's a security like is it
easy to manage authentication and
authorization if you're working any kind
of corporate or business world you
probably want to make sure you can you
can authenticate against aad because
that's what we tend to do you know push
it hard find out where the edges are and
then make a decision if you come away
from that and your team comes away and
they go Yep this is going to really work
for us then you look at taking it on but
don't just just because it's it's the
new kid on the Block
you know don't take lollies from it
they've probably got Hemlock in them or
something
the other thing you want to be consider
is looking at your overall scope so some
of these libraries that I was testing
during the time I was researching this I
was doing stuff I I have a thing for a
mono repo
frameworky thing called NX
which I think is really interesting I
need to do more working but one of the
other things I have a big thing for a
storybook
so I really like the idea of storybook
giving us a design system which is also
kind of helped me with testing and
verifying what it is so
the job of NX is that it defaults the
webpack
that's okay so I was trying solid and I
think solid defaults to using Vita
oh no it was even worse it was npmp and
p and PM
so yes there's a new there's a new
package manager out there
and I can tell you now don't run the
wrong command because you blow
everything up so the point was that
solid will not work with storybook at
this point now if storybook is an
essential part of your you know
development infrastructure and processes
don't take on a library this is going to
cause you Helen Mayhem
so
um
and this is the other problem with and
it goes back to and we'll cover this the
idea especially with the JavaScript
thing do you really need that
third-party Library one of the other
problems I've run into is that say the
primary framework or Library I'm using
decides it's going to do an update
now I know this happened with the
library with react when it went to 18.
but the library was still only developed
against react 17. so again I either
don't upgrade react or I break what that
third-party Library does and
unfortunately node modules is just a
weird creepy place where stuff is stored
so you you if you're looking at
assassinated things also look at what
your entire development process is
because it's going to be kind of
important if you make that decision and
you don't want to break it
okay
an app is not just for Christmas
I know you think it is but
um
the other problem I see quite frequently
is that you know say oh we've got the
three month project oh we're gonna I'm
gonna use solid and I'm going to you
know
I'm gonna use this you know CSS library
and stuff and there's a work grain we
build it
and then someone else comes along six
months later and has to work on it and
they look at it and go I've got no idea
you need to realize that when we build
web applications yeah project may only
take three months six months but it will
run for 10 or 12 years I said I've got
one out there which is used by ambulance
Victoria it's been going for nearly 12
years
24 7. Non-Stop
what do we do want to update it but
that's getting tricky so when you build
it don't when you think about what
libraries and stuff you're going to use
even that the solution structure that
you choose for managing your source code
is going to be important because what
does happen is that if developers don't
understand what the application does
they start doing weird stuff
and weird stuff again will bring us
performance issues a client former
client I had
um they who liked hiring stupid people
apparently that was actually in the
testing they used
um you know had they had to meet a
stupid marker
um
they had a asp.net application full
framework that's not the point
but they were using CSS
the problem is I kept bringing
developers and saying oh we need a new
button or we need to change the color of
this or you know we've got a new theme
it ended up having 25 style sheets that
were getting loaded every time the page
went up and they wondered why I was
running slowly and the worst part of it
it was really bad CSS and which I'll
cover in a second so
what we want to do is we want to make
sure that we set up everyone who follows
us and all the expansions we're going to
use for success I mean the other one is
um
visual studio and Dot net you know they
would have a you know Spa application so
you could do angular or react and I kept
sticking it into a web folder horrible
place for that stuff and it means it
makes it very hard to work on so
whatever you choose and wherever you go
think about not just now but think about
what's going to happen in 10 years
because if you're unlucky that's how
long it's going to last
know your HTML I bring this up because
again we keep coming back to Performance
and part of the issue with performance
is that we badly structure the initial
work we do
you know I am still seeing code now
where people put headers inside as a
difter they'll put tax in the div tag
the div tag is not designed for that
the div is a container that is all so
know your HTML actually understand it
it's a very rich markup language
it provides a lot of functioning and the
other key point and the one that's
coming up is the concepts of
accessibility the better
you use HTML the more accessible your
pages will be to users who need to rely
on screen readers or anything else it
also means that you actually end up not
writing too much HTML so you know again
I'll see people kind of Nest stuff all
the way down
you know now if I'm a screen reader I'm
going to give up halfway because it
walks too long but you know I think
you've got to come back you've got to
make sure your team actually understand
what this stuff is and this is my if and
I was not gonna
have a crackhead react but there you go
it was my problem with react and with
jsx is that it's not HTML so you bring a
Devon who doesn't really know HTML
starts working on react and Sunday
you're going to show them HTML I'm going
to try and type in class name
and it's not going to work because it
doesn't exist because you're not
actually getting the truth of what is
generated uh and I see this also with
third-party components especially in the
react World there's one I have a
particular hatred for and I looked I saw
I wonder what the hell this is doing and
it literally was divs from here till
tomorrow
for a text box
can't work that one out so know your
HTML
okay
the developer the component CSS
so
I wasn't going to put this one in but I
couldn't help myself
bootstrap we all know what bootstrap is
we all curse bootstrap
I think it's actually having a Revival
now I think it's coming from the dark
but bootstrap really solved a lot of
problems for us because developers are
inherently visually challenged I've
decided
so they need all the help they can get
there are also
not very good with CSS
and if I ever see a font size defined in
pixels again I'll spit
that's another story
um but bootstrap actually solved all our
problems for a lot of people it provided
a grid layout which was really useful
um you know you had a lot more you could
you could modify the colors it went to
SAS
um and that was kind of good and then we
had other ones more component libraries
and you know so manual manual um as I
say manual design
I've just gone blank material design
you know so again we've just found some
parameters kind of sexy you can have two
colors
um that was kind of weird uh
and then then we get further and further
down into the component Library
territory you know oh
need a calendar
selector
so you spend all your time looking at
different lives and probably if we
suddenly say oh well I've got this
Library I better bring it in and I'm
going to bring 20 other things in with
it again let's go back to Performance
we're not being selective to say well
I'm going to take this Library
because all I wanted was a calendar
selector
which he actually technically don't need
so
my thing is components are good and they
do solve some stuff for us but I would
then also say question whether you
always need them again if we look at
where we are with the state of HTML a
lot of the stuff that we used to need
components for we don't need it anymore
um you know except around some styling
things but even that's changing so
and again this is the thing this react
component library that I had The
Misfortune of inheriting
is one of the worst written things I've
ever seen if you actually I've actually
gone into their source code and I'm
scared
but because it looked really good and
shiny on the top so if you're going to
use components review them
actually put them in a page look at the
HTML they're generating make sure it's
HTML you could live with and that
someone's not going to pull up when you
do a job interview saying did you write
that
because they will along with the selfies
on Facebook so you know just got to be
careful with them as well
CSS is the thing we should be doing as
developers we need to be better with CSS
like HTML understand it is a basic
building block it is incredibly powerful
and it's more powerful you know every
couple of years they're bringing changes
in that's the libraries that help you
I'm a big fan of Tailwind CSS and I've
been working with that for quite a while
but don't always go to a component maybe
work out what you can do in CSS but if
you're going to use CSS use it prudently
don't just keep adding custom classes
all the way through it
CSS now I mean we used to use SAS a lot
because it allows us to Define variables
and then it would kind of Babel would do
its thing on it and you know we've got
that and but we've got variables in CSS
we can actually Nest stuff in CSS so the
bit like my agent tml statement review
what you're doing
and don't use pixels for font sizes
key takeaway
are we going for time ah rocking it
review your assumptions and be willing
to change
so this goes back again and one of the
things I was coming across a lot and
then this is very specifically the Spire
applications is that we have built
Things based on assumptions that we
might have had three years ago
so I'm trying to think of an example
calendar controls good one you know
there's actually native now there's a
lot of things
um making Ajax calls you know fetch
exists as an API we didn't need a
library to do that anymore
um
don't keep doing the same thing just
because that's the way you have always
done it
you need to stop and go okay I should
actually see if there is other ways of
doing this is there something better
but because we're we're face down in our
keyboards we tend to lose sight of
what's going on so you do need to re
review what your assumptions are about
the stuff you're implementing you know
do I really need it you know do I
actually need that 300 line JavaScript
maybe not
and be willing to change the other thing
that I have come across quite often is
that and if we go back to picking
Frameworks and whatever else you know
well you know we've made this decision
and then for the next six months they've
got a round Peg and a square hold and a
very large hammer
you have to be willing to say oops
we made a mistake this is not you know
we can't always tell but you're going to
hit some point and says this cannot do
what we want to do unless we do some
really weird stuff here
so I think the willingness to change now
I know this is really not easy if you're
working for a company or a client
and there's time pressures and stuff but
then I would argue we need to build in
that ability to change into our
engagement with our bosses and with our
teams with whoever
because if we do not practice adaption
and change we end up with something
we're going to regret
and we'll get back to that well it's not
performing really well because we ended
up using this library and we built this
JavaScript but it wasn't appropriate but
we can't change it
change is good
pragmatically and you need to change as
well
okay use the platform
I've kind of been covering this in a
kind of weird sort of roundabout way
back in the days of polymer anyone knew
what polymer was
ah
you are an older audience and I thought
this is good
um polymer was I think Google I was
promoting uh and it was like that really
early attempt to get web components into
the mainstream the problem was is that
they were actually like four years ahead
of themselves so a lot of the work had
to be poly filled and stuff ING bank and
this is where I first ran into when I
was working Madrid are big on polymer
and they're now big in web components so
there's another large organization using
web components and they had this you
know
spiffy hashtag use the platform it
actually sounded like some weird
religious cult actually and you know you
see videos and they're all Smiley and
use the platform
this is not what I'm talking about
the again
you know we're seeing all this Mayhem
over here but things like
browsers and the the web apis are on a
constant growth path
they they're steadily just going along
doing stuff
so use the platform is saying if I can
use an API
a web API in the browser I don't need to
build this weird custom code
you know fetch apis a very obvious one
that changed how we thought about making
Ajax calls it simplified it there's a
there's a an API that's in beta that's
actually going to help doing page
Transitions and literally
it has two tags and it takes a snapshot
of the screen holds on to it while you
go to the next page and then does a
merge and across it's it's seriously in
beta but it's cool now we have to write
that stuff now so always come back to
what can I use that's already there in
the browser what functionality can I
make useful to me and why do we want to
do this because if we go back to final
point an earlier Point performance I can
probably reduce the JavaScript I have to
write which means I'm going to reduce
the JavaScript that I'm going to
actually have to push up to the browser
and this goes back to reviewing your
assumptions don't always assume that
you've written something one way that
there isn't a better way of doing it now
oh I'm doing good today okay so in
summary there is no Silver Bullet
so I think we always live in Hope of one
as long as it doesn't hit us
um there's a lot happening and there's a
lot more coming around the corner this
is you know there there is there is
things going on
and it'll be interesting to see what
sticks and what fails and this is always
the tricky part because at some point
you've got to back some horse
my personal opinion at the moment is
have a look at some of the newer
libraries and stuff but maybe stick with
what's working well for you
because
um and as an example I was looking up
snowpack which is another
bundler stuff and I had been looking and
thinking of using it and I went on the
website to look something up and they've
stopped supporting it since 2020.
something like that you know so
you know some of this stuff is looking
really cool but is it going to have
longevity
it just goes back to saying your
application is going to live longer than
the three months that your project runs
so we're going to take that into account
my main concern is that the Hurley
Burley whether we're seeing we can lose
sight of what is important which is
building applications for people to use
and I will always come back to this
people your end users are the ones that
are going to matter in the end whether
it's a marketing website which I quite
honestly can't get excited about
or an application that's going to be
used in an office this can be used in a
hospital
it's going to be on the phone it's going
to be on a desktop it's going to be on
giant monitors the people who are using
your applications are the ones that
matter and so we should always Focus
back at that point
these are this stuff I've talked about
they're they're our toolkit
you know I'm the carpenter this is a
toolkit I carry but if I'm building a
house all we really need to know is not
what is the house made of but is the
house fit for purpose
that's where we should be going with
this stuff
um
and that's it
I rounded and I think I only swore twice
three four times thank you very much
it's been a pleasure talking to you
I've got two minutes has anyone actually
got any questions
yes at the back
hybrid
if there's such a butter and the new
Microsoft now is coming out oh look
look I think they're interesting the
number of times I have seen the build
once run everywhere has been long
and it goes way back to Java so I
remember the first time someone I was at
the University they built a Java
application rolled it out as a piece of
I'm going to put it simply six
um I think they're interesting and I
think this is the point about re
checking your assumptions always go back
give it a run but if it's going to block
you then maybe you want to pull back and
like I said mitosis interests me because
it actually provides maybe a third path
given that in in such an organizations
you may have applications built across
multiple Frameworks and libraries any
other questions
good as again thank you very much and
it's been a pleasure